- Spider-Man: Far From Home
is out and, as of this taping,
is certified fresh at
92%, continuing the MCU's
marvelous rate of 23
consecutive fresh films.
Not a single rotten, 21 of
which are certified fresh
but is it the best
Spider-Man movie of all time?
Hi, everyone, I'm Mark Ellis.
That is my true identity and
welcome to the Aftershow.
This is a spoiler-heavy
show, so if you haven't seen
the new Spider-Man movie
yet, I did my best.
I am so excited to welcome
this panel to the show.
First of all, we have Geek
Bomb host, Maude Garrett
is back.
- Hi!
- So glad to be here for this
one, especially, it's so good!
- This is going to be a
fun conversation, for sure.
And joining us Rotten
Tomatoes certified critic
and pop culture critic, the one and only,
Ms. Joelle Monique is here.
- Hi!
- I'm so excited to be here.
- I am so excited to have
you and were we really
going to talk Spider-Man
without this next guy,
Scott Movie Mantz--
- Yes!
- Our returning champion is back.
- Returning champion Spider-Mantz
meets Spider-Man, come on.
We're going to have a great conversation
about Far From Home.
Man, these Spider-Man movies are awesome.
- They just keep getting
awesomer, according to
the Tomatometer, anyway,
so before we get into
our spoiler-heavy
conversation about all things
Spider-Man: Far From Home,
I do want to throw it
to my panelists individually
to just to get your quick take,
is this a fresh or rotten movie?
Joelle, start with you, fresh or rotten?
- Absolutely fresh, we're getting
our first mainstay villain
in a really long time.
Tom continues to hit it
out of the park as, like,
our sweet, adorable, like,
cherub, baby Spider-Man
and I love him.
- Yeah.
- And, on top of that,
we get, like, a possibly
a new MJ angle which I'm
really excited to explore.
- I am definitely with
you with the MJ angle.
Scott Mantz, do I even
have to ask the question?
- This is fresh by a mile and
you gotta look at this way,
not only did you have Spider-Man appearing
in Avengers: Infinity War,
and End Game, and Homecoming,
and Into the Spider-Verse,
which won the Oscar
for best animated
feature but Far From Home
still feel likes a fresh, vibrant movie
and that's a feat unto itself.
- All right.
- Maude Garrett, you agree
with your two co-panels?
- Fresh, fresh, fresh, fresh!
This is like such a beautiful
movie, especially, like,
after the gravitas that was End Game,
a lot of feels there
but we're kind of like,
coming out of it and
enjoying these so much.
Jake Gyllenhaal, fantastic,
he's having the time
of his life.
- Yep.
- I love Spider-Man and I
think that it's the best
it's ever been.
- I cannot believe that I'm
the only person on this show
that is going to say that
Spider-Man: Far From Home
is not rotten, I was just teasing y'all.
Of course, it's a fresh movie.
(laughs)
I do have some issues with the movie.
I have some things that
I want to get into,
the first of which is
the villain, Mysterio,
because I've seen a lot of
people raving about how much
they love Jake Gyllenhaal in this movie,
that this could be one
of the best MCU villains
that they've seen, so that's
some heavy company to be in,
Maude, when you look at
somebody like a Thanos,
or a Killmonger, or a Loki.
Where does Mysterio rank as far as
your favorite MCU villain?
- I honestly don't think
it's fair to kind of
put him in line with all those other ones.
You've got Thanos, you've got, you know,
all of these villains
that have the greater good
kind of aspect where they
really do believe that
what their motive is is
the betterment of society.
Jake Gyllenhaal and Mysterio
is a disgruntled employee.
He's just an angry, angry
guy that feels like, maybe,
all the money, and success, and notoriety
shouldn't have gone to
someone like Tony Stark
and that he was treated
poorly and he's unifying
disgruntled employee around
the world but using technology
to prove the point which
is like exactly really
what Tony Stark did using
technology to kind of gain power.
But he's using it against him.
- [Mark] Yeah, and, Scott,
we've seen this angle before
in the MCU as it relates
to Tony Stark and a former
disgruntled employee, so.
- Right.
- Did you just see a lot of
shades of Justin Hammer here,
was this a little too Ultron-y for you,
was this like, again,
we're mad at Tony Stark
and we have to form something
that gets our revenge?
- Okay, well, this is not
the first time we've seen
a disgruntled employee
in a superhero movie.
Remember Amazing Spider-Man 2,
Electro was a disgruntled
employee and remember,
wasn't it Batman Forever
in which the Joker
was a disgruntled ex-employee?
- You're pulling out all
the comic book movie hits.
- Right, but that's the
thing is that it's been done.
What hasn't been done
is the use of Mysterio.
Now, as a life-long
Spider-Man fan, I've loved how
they've gone back and they've
mined the classic villains
like The Green Goblin,
Sandman, you know, Electro
wasn't so hot but Doc Ock was great.
But I've always felt like
Electro was underappreciated,
overlooked as a villain,
he made is first appearance
in Amazing Spider-Man
number 13 back in 1964.
And with today's special
effects in these movies,
it's like the perfect
playhouse, a great wheelhouse
for a character like Mysterio.
So, to update him as a
disgruntled ex-Stark employee,
I thought, was a good
touch and Jake Gyllenhaal,
he was great but, at first,
it took me a little while
to warm up to him and here's why--
- Smoke and mirrors, baby!
- Smoke and mirrors.
- 'Cause you didn't really,
but this is a good thing
about the film, you
didn't know, in the movie,
what Mysterio's motive was.
- Yeah, yeah, Joelle, I
want you to jump in on that
real quick because we, as
hardcore comic book fans or,
at least, people that follow
the news, we know that
Jake Gyllenhaal has been cast
as this villainous presence
but I think that people
watching this movie,
my mom might watch this movie
and assume, oh, this is Jake,
puppy-dog-eye Gyllenhaal--
(laughs)
He's gonna be a good guy
teaming up with Spider-Man.
- Yeah, I think that's what
really works about it, actually.
I think we have had a lot
of disgruntled employee
kind of villains but they're
so angry and I feel like
he's not as angry at Tony
Stark as he is seeing
an opportunity to build himself.
I think he's much less
disgruntled and more like,
I, too, am a genius and
I haven't had my moment
in the spotlight and
now I'm gonna seize it
because Tony Stark is gone.
I also think it expands the world in such
an interesting way, you
now have regular people
who are like, I'm gonna get
in this superhero action.
Whereas, before, everyone's
like, I kinda don't want to,
or I just have to stop
something bad, like,
the world is gonna end if I don't suit up.
Whereas, now, we just
have guys who are like,
I just have, like, some theatrical stuff.
- But also, what's great,
and I agree with you,
I like how they just, sort
of, they've made it current,
they've made the character fit
by making him less of a hero,
more of a master of technology.
But, true to the original
character of Mysterio,
he is the master of illusion
and there is a scene
in this movie where Mysterio
really messes with Spider-Man,
driving him bonkers that,
I swear, could have come
right out of a page from
Amazing Spider-Man number 67,
Stan Lee drama meter
and it is a great scene.
And I'm sitting there watching
the movie going, like,
yeah, this is exactly how I
envisioned them using Mysterio
in a big MCU movie.
- Well, I'm watching that
scene myself and I'm saying,
this is such a worthy
opponent to all the powers
that Spider-Man has, then
at the end of the movie,
Spider-Man just remembered
that he had Spidey-sense
and he built himself a suit--
(laughs)
You know, my favorite part
of the Mysterio Spider-Man
was actually the chemistry
that they had together
when he was being that
father-figure and then,
once Mysterio just manifested as a villain
by the end of the movie,
I just thought it was,
I don't want to use the word
forgettable because he did
bring some things to the
MCU but I don't think that
as we get farther into these
movies, I think we're going to
look at a first appearance for
a villain like a Killmonger
or a Loki, I think, are the two best ones
that we've seen yet, and
I think that Mysterio
might just be, he's not a
Malekith but he's just another--
- Okay.
- Another dude.
- And you're saying that because,
maybe, you just don't have
the knowledge, maybe, of
the character that some
other people--
(guffaws)
- Scott, wow!
- Probably, likely, yeah.
- There you go.
- But I--
- I disagree, just in that I
think that Mysterio is not,
because he's so different
than all the other villains,
I don't think he's gonna
get, to me, like, Ultron
is one of the most forgettable villains.
Like, he doesn't have--
- I agree.
- Like a strong, central
motivation other than destroy.
I feel like Mysterio's desire to be seen,
especially as we've just let
all of the Avengers being like,
so that was wild, man, and we
gotta go like soul-searching
and we gotta get back to
our roots and we're not here
for the celebrity or even to be, you know,
spotlighted and lifted up,
we're just going to help
in the background, now,
is sort of, kind of
where everyone's gone to.
I think having villains
like Loki who are like,
I'm gonna shower down giant cloud-monsters
to destroy the earth, I
think it's going to have to
bring the Avengers back
out into the spotlight
and I think if Mysterio
is leading the charge,
especially knowing how charming he is,
knowing how good Marvel is as
revamping and angling, like,
I'll agree with that it might
have been a little bit light
but I think that's what
the MCU tends to do.
They're like, well, we're
not quite sure what people
will like, we'll right
something very strong
and then we'll let the
fans tell us what they like
and we'll surprise them later.
- And it's also that MCU is
still rebounding the fans
from everything that went on in End Game.
- So true.
- We just had such a
heavy, really, two movies
with Infinity War and
the End Game and you put
Captain Marvel in the middle
of that and so, it was nice
just to have a movie like
Spider-Man: Far From Home
that has such a great sense
of humor and is so refreshing
in that regard.
- I completely agree with you, Mark,
because here's the
beauty of Far From Home.
So, first of all, it works as
a standalone Spider-Man film.
Second of all, I think,
it's a superior film
to 2017's Homecoming, okay.
- I agree.
- And sec--
- And not many people do.
- Well, it's a bit split.
- Yeah, it's a split.
- But I definitely felt
like it was superior
in most of the ways because,
also, what this movie does,
it is a coda to Avengers: End Game.
It extends phase three of the
MCU just a little bit further,
maybe inching towards phase
four just a little bit.
Like, for people who just
wanted a little bit more
after End Game, which is a
heavy movie, a lot of deep,
emotional moments, here's a
movie that's just super fun.
It's a perfect blend of
action, heart, and humor.
Perfect for the July 4th weekend.
- Yeah, before we move
on to our namesake here,
I just want to get y'alls quick take.
Does this kill the idea
of a multiverse because,
you know, it was teased
and now it's kind of
the fake backstory.
So, does this mean we're
not getting a multiverse
anytime soon in the MCU?
- Not at all.
- Or does it mean that
it's actually more likely?
- Listen, again, looking at the structure
of typical Marvel movies, we look back at
Captain America: The First
Avenger, we know that they like
to tease, like, here's some Thor stuff.
It's just pictures, just
hanging in the background.
I think mentioning it
actually means we're going to
get closer to it.
I think, because you get Peter
pontificating of like, well,
how would that work and it
gives you six different ways
that it could possibly work.
I think we're going to get
it sooner rather than later
and I think we're gonna come
back later to this movie and go
that's where they were
teasing and that's where
they were teasing it.
- Maude, your body language says agree.
- Absolutely, the fact
that they've said the word
means that it exists.
I tried to get out of Amy Pascal
with into the Spider-Verse
the fact that the multiverse
is definitely in existence
and I was like, is the canon
and are we leading into
that and will we see that
split multiverse in an
upcoming Spider-Man movie,
to which she was incredibly tight-lipped.
(laughs)
Of course.
But this is the second
time we've really seen
or heard about it.
Even though it was smoke and
mirrors, I mean, hello that's--
- That's Mysterio.
- That's it.
- Yeah, I liked it a little
bit just as if nothing else
is a nod to what we
got with the, you know,
Into the Multiverse movie
but I think that we could be
seeing more of the multiverse
coming up in the MCU.
- I would also love to see a
live action Miles Morales--
- Yes, please!
- Spider-Man movie.
- Female Doc Ock, in the
flesh would be great too.
- Oh yeah, that would be awesome.
- She was great in that.
- This could really go far.
- Okay, well, while we pitch
more Spider-Man movies,
let's move on to the Spider-Man
that we currently have
and we should be very happy
with and that would be
Tom Holland and, in this
movie, the way that Tom Holland
kind of tries to take the
mantle from Tony Stark,
I feel like Tony Stark is
always going to be a presence
in these movies, going forward,
even though it's just going
to be the spirit of Tony
Stark living, breathing
through Spider-Man, is he
the successor to Tony Stark,
in your eyes, Scott?
- Okay, well, first of all,
I agree that, in this film,
definitely feels not just
like Tony Stark is a presence,
it feels like he's in the
movie and he kind of is
in one particular scene.
This movie is a love letter to
Tony Stark and it is a great
passing of the torch,
a passing of the baton
from Tony Stark who saw
Peter Parker as a great,
not just a protege but,
like, next in line to really
take charge of the Avengers and he's only,
like you said, Mark, he's 16 years old.
There's a whole lot of
places for this to go but,
I think with this film,
again, it's a coda to End Game
where we saw, again, spoiler
alert, this is a big one,
we saw Iron Man, he's gone, he's out.
So, this sort of feels
like a further coda to him
and a tribute to his character
but, I think, after this,
you're going to see and feel
the presence of Tony Stark
much, much further in the rearview mirror.
- It felt like the end of
End Game for a while there,
Joelle, but then, once
we get Spidey on the jet
and he's hanging out with
Happy and he's building
his own suit, it's like,
this is the new Tony Stark.
Do you look at Spider-Man
as the new face of the MCU?
Should he be the new face of the MCU?
- Should he, I mean,
he's capable of doing it.
I think people love Tom
Holland, they're having really
great reactions to him.
I think, what I really love about the MCU
is that it's sort of all-encompassing
but it also has like,
it's dealing with a lot
of adult themes and stuff.
Spider-Man is still very young, to me.
I think Tony leaving
weapons of mass destruction
to a 16 year old is--
(laughs sarcastically)
Questionable parenting.
- But it's so Tony.
- But, that being said, so, I'll say this,
I'm not sure about
Spider-Man being the center
of the Marvel Universe,
he's your friendly,
neighborhood Spider-Man.
- Not anymore.
- How is he going to lead
the Avengers and how's Thor
going to take orders from Spider-Man?
And it's just a lot of weirdness
on that level, however,
if we're talking about
a spiritual inheritance
of the role Tony gave
which is sort of the heart
of the MCU, the guy people
turned to when they're not
quite sure how they're
feeling about something,
I think his decision to step
back, he took the exact same
route Tony took after Infinity War.
He's like, I just want
to be with my family,
I'm not putting on this suit,
I'm just going to step away.
I'll monitor things, I'm
gonna check in but, please,
don't involve me, and I think
that he was trying to achieve
what Tony achieved while he
was gone and I think that
makes him the spiritual
inheritor of Tony's legacy.
- And if Tony Stark was the
spiritual leader of MCU,
I would still argue that
Captain America was the face
of the Avengers--
- He was the soul, yep.
- And we had a Captain America cameo
and there's Anthony Mackie's
taking over for Captain America
but that got cut at the
end 'cause they didn't want
to undercut what was already
happening in the third scene,
so I would have loved
to have seen that cameo.
So, maybe, hope for the Blu-ray.
Do you think that Spider-Man
is the logical choice
to be the face of the MCU or do you have
another candidate, Maude?
- I want to step out from
sort of the law of it all
and the hypothetical
and I want to talk about
the Hollywood budgets
and that side of things.
I think that you've got
Tom Holland who was brought
on board as the no-name
and that he is, now,
all-encompassing as a Marvel superhero.
I think that they can afford him,
I think that they've signed
him on to a 10 year deal.
He, himself, has said
that he'll play Spider-Man
for the rest of his life.
I think that the Tom Holland
is the new Hugh Jackman,
whereas, we are going to
see this guy play Spider-Man
for the next 16 years.
Like, I think the tenure's
going to be very long
and established and
that's going to be great.
Is he ever going to replace Tony Stark?
- No.
- No, we need the juxtaposition
between the ingrained heroes
that have the life
experience, that, you know,
that the end of the world
is constantly on their mind
and then bringing it back
to what is human, like,
what's so human and what's
innocent which is Spider-Man
just wanting to kiss a girl that he likes.
You need both of them.
- See, that's the thing.
- That's the thing,
Spider-Man still has a lot
of growing up to do.
He's only 16 years old.
We haven't seen him get the
job yet at the Daily Bugle
working for J. Jonah Jameson--
- That's not gonna happen!
- That's not gonna happen, that's done.
- That's not gonna happen?
- No.
- He's not gonna get a
job as a photographer
for the Daily Bugle?
- Because he's out already.
- The first thing that happened
in that post-credit scene
when J. Jonah Jameson is like,
"Peter Parker," dah-dah-dah--
- Which was, by they way, was awesome!
- It was awesome.
- But he knows his name.
- This is why I really
don't have to work at all
as a host because--
(laughs boisterously)
Our next topic is, as a matter of fact,
that incredible post-credit
scene where you do have,
and it was good post-credit
scene anyway because it did give
Mysterio kind of a life
after supposed death
and we're like, oh god, he
revealed it, I can't believe it,
and then, at least the theater
that Joelle and I were in--
- Mnh-mnh.
- Exploded when J. Jameson--
- Yes.
- That was great.
- Played by J.K. Simmons
back on the screen,
our theater was making so
much noise and rightfully so,
I couldn't really understand
where he was going with it
for a while and then I picked
up that he is anti-Spider-Man
and he's just very, kind
of, blogger-y, like,
I'm gonna attack Spider-Man
with this grain of salt
of possible truth that I have.
So, I like where that was
going just as somebody
who wants to be entertained
in the moment but, now,
as we step back and look
at what this actually does
for the MCU, we know who
Spider-Man is now, Joelle,
how is that gonna change?
- Everyone does.
- What isn't gonna change?
Everything changes, especially
because, here was I'll be
most interested to see is,
we know Peter does not want
anybody he's around to be hurt
and he says, consistently,
throughout the movie, if
my identity is revealed,
I'm not going to be doing this.
So, do we come back and
Peter's like, nah, man,
I'm just Peter now?
But, also, Spider-Man has
such a strong relationship
with New York and it's
one of my favorite things
about Homecoming, which
is still my favorite
Spider-Man movie of
all time, was this idea
of how connected he is.
How does New York let Peter
Parker just go by now?
Like, you are Spider-Man, so
it'll be interesting to see
and maybe that's the way
they force him to get
into the Avengers, if he skips The Bugle,
if he, you know, instead
of going to college,
he's got a ton of great
professors already around him
in the Avengers, maybe
they're training him up,
teaching him and he's, I don't
know, learning how to run
Tony Stark Corporation?
(chuckles)
- But he's still a kid, he
needs to have the experience
of college to grow as a person.
You know, yeah, sure, he's
around the best people
who could really mentor
him in the Avengers
but he need to grow as a
person to have the experience--
- I hear what you're
saying but Generation Z,
as far as like, if you're
looking at kids right now
who are Spider-Man's age,
many of them are not going
to college, they just can't afford it.
And so, maybe they lean more
into the current generation
of how they're navigating the world.
- That's a great point.
- They can't afford it or
they make hundreds of millions
of dollars going right
the NBA and LeBron James
had done a pretty good job
of not going to college.
- Or they're YouTubers--
- I would say LeBron James
is the best superhero
we have on earth right now,
he is our current Spider-Man
and if you look at where
Peter Parker's going, Scott,
I think that, honestly, the
best use for him right now,
because I do agree with what
you said is that he is a kid
and he's not ready to handle
the responsibility that,
I think--
- With great power.
- That Anthony Mackie's, Falcon,
now, Captain America could
or what T'Challa could.
- What about T'Challa,
that's who I'm thinking.
- But here's the thing, with
Spider-Man, because we know
who Peter Parker is, I think
he is a great distraction.
I think that he is
something you can dangle
in front of villains and
they all go after him
and we have all these other
Avengers that can just
come out of the woodwork
and that's how you
take down a threat.
- No matter what, no
matter what he grows into,
whether he goes to work
for the Daily Bugle--
- [Maude] It's not gonna
happen, he can't do it.
- Whether he goes to
Empire State University,
whether he meets Gwen Stacy,
whether he starts dating
Betty Brant who they
introduced in Far From Home--
- How dare you, he's not gonna
date his best friend's ex.
- Well, I mean--
- How dare you!
- Betty Brant--
- There are best friend rules.
- Whose husband was the
Hobgoblin but I'm totally going
off the rails here, but the
other thing is, you know,
as much as I love Far From
Home, the problem I have
with the film, and this
is a problem, is that
while it's really cool to see
Spider-Man finally interact
and pal around with Iron
Man and Captain America
and the rest of the Avengers in the MCU,
there's something to be
said about having a movie
that's just about Spider-Man.
I just want a movie about
Spider-Man which is why,
in terms of live action
movies, Spider-Man 2 from 2004
with Tobey Maguire, directed
by Sam Raimi, to me,
is still the best Spider-Man
movie of them all.
- I think that's why you're
not getting the standalone,
'cause we've already had
that, it's already been done
and I think that that was
a really poignant moment
that I had during the end
credits scene where it was like,
well, we know Spider-Man's
story so well because this is
the third iteration that we've seen.
And I was ready, I was bracing
myself for when he does
become a photographer for the
Daily Bugle because it's like
that's the story that I
know and I'm ready for it.
So, to hear that that's
off the table, now,
we are now venturing
into mysterious ground.
- Ha, ha.
- Where this is like, you
know, unfamiliar territory.
So I'm sad that we're not going
to see Tom Holland's version
of what that looks like
but we've got a whole new
stage here.
- How cool for the fans.
- What keeps this movie from
being the best live action
movie for me though is
that it's such a busy film.
There's so much going on,
they're going all over Europe,
you have all these supporting characters
in Peter Parker's life, you
have all these other characters
in the MCU like, Happy
Hogan, and Nick Fury
and there's so much story going
on, too, that I felt like,
at times, that Spider-Man was a guest star
in his own movie.
And as a Spider-Man fan,
I just want a movie about Spider-Man.
- Okay, what if they give
you a movie about Spider-Man,
possibly the next standalone
Spider-Man movie we get
but that has Venom in it as well?
Because they could have Tom Hardy Venom.
If you're gonna put J.K. Simmons back
as J. Jonah Jameson,
anything's possible now.
So, Joelle, do you think that we could see
Tom Hardy's Venom go up
against Tom Holland's Spidey?
- Let me control my face.
(laughs)
I am so sorry, fans, who
love this iteration of Venom.
Your point and love are totally valid
and I respect them, oh, Lord,
I don't like that version
of Venom, I don't understand it.
I think, we were talking a
little bit before the show
about how, sort of,
expansive that character is
based off of how the Venom movie ended,
so maybe it could morph
into something else.
I'll say, Marvel could
do it; I hope they don't.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] I think they will do it, Scott.
- I think they will do it
and I think that, listen,
I did not like the standalone Venom movie
but I did like, not love, but
I did think that Spider-Man 3
from 2007, not the best Spider-Man movie
but not the worst either.
It has its moments.
Oh, come on, Maude!
(laughs)
You know, you're giving
me the dark Peter Parker.
Listen, that scene was a
bit much, but Eddie Brock
is played by--
- Topher Grace.
- Topher Grace in the movie.
- My doppelganger, yes.
- I thought that he was actually
really good but, I think,
obviously, there's a lot of
potential for a really great
Venom villain against
Spider-Man, that's coming.
All the fans definitely want to see it,
they need to get that right
and I think that's coming soon.
- But they're going to
make it into a bunny movie
at the end 'cause everyone likes
Venom and they kind of like
that he's this, like--
- Anti-hero.
- Maude, is Venom a
villainous enough presence
to go up against Spidey or
do you just want to see him--
- I want Tom squared.
(laughs)
I want to see Tom Holland
and I want to see Tom Hardy.
And I want to see them Tom together.
- [Scott] Tom Squared, ha!
(laughs)
- I just want some Tom time.
- I like Tom is being
used as a verb but ja-ren
to everything else, it's an adverb.
- [Maude] It is Tom for that movie.
(laughs)
(exclaims)
- It's Tom to move on to
the next post-credits scene
which was another twist
that we got that really blew
the MCU wide open because
we thought we were watching
Nick and Maria.
(chuckles)
We weren't, we were watching
Skrulls play the role
and then Nick Fury's off doing other stuff
in more of a Captain Marvel
sort of setting, so--
- [Maude] He's having a holiday.
- He's on--
- The man deserved it.
- [Maude] He's done how many
movies already as Nick Fury?
- He was having a fake holiday,
then he gets off the screen
then he says back to work,
so do you like that twist
that it wasn't actually
Nick Fury the entire time
in Far From Home, Maude Garrett?
- All right, so here's a
little thing that I'm noticing
with Marvel, we're starting
to fall into crutches
and these two things
that we've established
in the Marvel Universe, now,
can kind of solve any problem.
And that is the introduction of Skrulls
being shapeshifters and,
potentially, playing anyone
which is good and bad
because the good thing is,
I, now, want to watch this
movie again and find these
quite, now, obvious hits that
it wasn't them, necessarily.
Like, they had met before,
Nick Fury and Spider-Man,
and he said nice to meet you.
And I was like, that's a little weird,
maybe I can't remember.
So, it's like, I like those little payoffs
but at the same time, it's
like, someone's gonna die
and then they turn into a Skrull.
And you're like, oh, cool.
- Right.
- The other one is time travel, you know.
So we've seen that that's an easy fix,
so if you don't like it, go
back in time and do it again.
So I think that these are two
very blanket, very clever,
but very forgiving kind of
crutches that they can lean into.
- [Mark] Yeah, Scott, I
had the pleasure of seeing
this movie last week and,
so, I said I'm going to
give myself the weekend and
then I'll know how I feel
about this post-credit
scene but I have no idea
how to feel; tell me how to feel.
- Okay, well, first of
all, I hate to say this but
the better credit scene was the big reveal
to the city of New York and to the world
that Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
What came after that was
the reveal of Nick Fury
as a Skrull.
I didn't really care that much
about it because I did not
care for the movie, Captain Marvel.
I thought it was bland,
I thought it was weak,
and I just really didn't
think that the character
really stood out.
(laughs)
Sorry, I thought that--
(stammers)
- [Joelle] I thought
we were friends, Scott.
- I'm gonna get a lot of
heat for this but I thought
that Captain Marvel was the
weakest movie in the MCU.
(blows raspberry)
- Have seen Thor: Dark World?
- Thor: Dark World is also
not good and neither is
Iron Man 2 and neither is
Guardians of the Galaxy 2.
- Okay, so defend this
post-credits scene for us, Joelle,
because why--
- Listen.
- Why is this so important
that, oh, Nick Fury
is off doing what?
- Nick is our link across the MCU.
He is the thing that
brings us all together.
So, I was personally shocked
when people were like,
like, I knew, instantly, something
was wrong with Nick Fury.
Like, Mysterio's antics,
not that great, like,
after the bar scene, there's
no reason, Nick Fury,
who's a thousand times smarter
than me isn't picking up
on these things, something is wrong.
And then, the whole time,
I'm freaking, I'm like,
what are they doing to Nick
Fury, like, he came back
and he's disoriented and
he doesn't have context,
and Spider-Man is the only
one he can reach out to.
There are still so many
people on the planet earth.
This is a setup or something
weird is happening,
I don't understand it.
Then we get to the end and
there's just great reveal
of like, Nick is off-world,
he is setting up the Skrulls
to build or sustain something on earth,
we don't know what it is.
What is your mission in out space,
what are you doing out there,
do you need more heroes,
are you concerned, are you--
- Secret Wars.
- Oh!
- Maybe, I'm not really, I
don't want to say Secret Wars.
- I think we just won Mantz over.
- Whoa.
(laughs)
- Secret Wars.
- That's what's happening.
- The Beyonder?
- Yes!
- Oh man, mind blown!
(laughs)
(imitates gunshot)
- This is why we show up
and do these shows because--
- Oh my god, I didn't thing about that.
- [Mark] We have our
opinions, they can be changed
during the course of a conversation.
- Oh my gosh.
- Well, there you go.
- Whether you're watching at
home or you're hosting the show
and you're not sure what Secret Wars is--
- [Scott] I gotcha.
- Just give me quick
run-through from each panelist.
- Okay, back in the early
80s, 1984, to be exact,
the Marvel Universe was shaken up
when all the greatest
heroes like Spider-Man,
Fantastic Four, the Hulk,
and the greatest villains
like Doctor Doom and so on,
were taken to another world
by a great being called
The Beyonder who made them
fight each other and whoever
won would have the powers
of the Beyonder and be able
to control the universe.
It is actually a story that,
in terms of the movies,
could be bigger in the stakes than even
Avengers: Infinity War and End
Game and I like the concept
of that's actually where
phase four could go.
- So, basically, Spider-Man,
we know you used to love
being your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man
and saving delis; it's gonna
get a little bigger than that.
(snickers)
(laughs)
- We have one more topic
to get to and that would be
your overarching thought
about how we ended phase three
because this is the official
end of phase three, now,
as we get into phase four.
And where does this rank in
your favorite Spider-Man films
of all time?
Joelle, I'll start with you.
- Okay.
- Fitting end to phase
three, the right movie
to launch phase four?
- I think if we had had
that Captain America scene,
I would feel better about
this being the start of four.
To me, this was such a...
You caught like an addendum.
I don't like it, I don't like.
To me, I don't need a
post-credit scene movie.
- I see what you're saying.
- You know what I mean?
- We had a definitive
ending and it was so good
and I came into this, partly,
where are we going with four?
- [Maude] It's literally
called End Game as well.
- Exactly, that's the end
of it, so people were like,
it's like an extension of three.
Well, who needs that,
like, why are we here?
I feel like, what I was
really hoping for was like,
what's the new direction, is
it Avengers, are Avengers like,
we don't have Tony anymore,
we need to start going
in a new direction, is it
gonna be the teasing of X-Men?
And it turns out, it's
the teasing, possibly,
of Secret Wars but it, to me,
it didn't connect to anything.
I still feel out in space, I
don't know what's happening
in phase four, I didn't really
need an ending for three.
- I feel like it's the
exhale after being punched
in the gut.
- Bingo!
- So it's like, ho--
(gasps)
All right we're back.
- I need a breath.
- And I don't feel like it's a full stop.
It's not like the end, it's not like,
it's almost like the
webbing, pun intended,
between the two.
So it's like the inhale
that you get to back
into the next one.
I don't see it as a start
end, you know, like,
it's not black and white like that.
- I think it's something we'll
be able to measure better
five or six films out when
we can understand, again,
the great thing about the
MCU is that it is developing
universal story telling.
It's been my obsession
since I was a child,
I love crossover, I love,
like, extending universes.
It's why I like the fact that
we have like 8000 stories
in here because if you're an MCU die-hard
and you've seen all
these movies and you've
watched them again, these
stories are super easy to follow
because you're like, oh hey, Happy's here,
that's really cool.
I think that rewatch-ability
of this movie is going to be
so high, there's so much
to go back and be like,
oh, I see that there and
like, I see how this connects
to our future stuff, so I'm
looking forward to our next
three movies coming and then
coming back to revisit this.
- Scott does rewatch-ability,
for you, make a great film?
So does that elevate Far
From Home above Homecoming,
is that why you have that ranking?
- Absolutely, rewatch-ability
makes a movie.
I mean, I've seen Into the
Spider-Verse like four times now
and there's so much to Into
the Spider-Verse, especially
Easter eggs for MCU
fans and Spider-Man fans
to find so many things and
also the depth of that film
which I saw as the It's A Wonderful Life
of Spider-Man movies
which we could talk about
on another Aftershow for
Into the Spider-Verse
which we could do, like, anyway.
But I saw Far From Home,
like I said, at the top
of the show, as a coda, as
an epilogue to End Game.
What you just said, Maude,
about it being sort of like
catching your breath after
being punched in the gut,
End Game was a very heavy movie,
a lot of emotional moments
and it ended--
- [Maude] I cried for 20 minutes straight.
- It ended phase three in a
really emotional satisfying way,
you know, 22 movies, 11 years,
but this is sort of like
peeking ahead of what happens after that.
I'd like to just know,
what happens after that?
And it doesn't really
advance into phase four
in any definitive way
except for, I guess, that
post-credit scene that I
like a whole lot more now
than I did 10 minutes ago.
(chuckles)
But I think it's going
to be a rewatch-able film
and, yeah, on first viewing,
I thought it was a very
busy movie but maybe I'll
like it better when I watch it
again and again.
- I just had an epiphany.
(groans)
- Here we go.
So, we don't get Peter Parker
working for the Daily Bugle
because he's no longer
anonymous but guess who is?
- Is it MJ?
- Mary Jane?
- No, Miles Morales.
- Oh!
- What if Miles Morales gets
hired as a graphic designer?
- Wow.
- Or the likes?
- Oh my gosh.
- And works at the Bugle?
- [Scott] You are killing
me, you are killing me.
- [Mark] Joelle came
hard to the hole with her
MJ prediction and then, you
topped it with Miles Morales.
So--
- Oh, my god.
- And that's how we get Miles in there.
- Oh my god, this is like
the greatest Aftershow ever.
- [Joelle] Are you secretly
writing for Marvel?
- This is what we're doing
right now as fans of the MCU
is that we're looking into
phase four and saying, well,
this is what we most want to see.
One of the things I
would love to see in more
Spider-Man movie is more of
Mary Jane, I want to see more
of Zendaya because I thought
she was so good in this movie.
I think it was a giant leap
getting to know her character
a little bit more--
- And I kinda wish we had a
little bit more of that secrecy,
you know, like that
secret society that they
both have together and she's
holding the biggest secret
on her shoulders--
- [Mark] And then, as soon as she knew it,
it wasn't a secret anymore.
- I definitely feel like
they did more with her
and had to cut out
because she has maybe two
really good character pivots
in the movie that we don't get
any kind of like lead in
to, she sort of just like,
and now I'm a spy and I was
like, dang it, could we have
had little teases of this earlier.
She's so great in the role--
- But we had so much work to
do setting up phase four though
so we got a lot--
- [Joelle] It's true, I know
there's a lot happening.
- So, if I give you one
event that need to happen
in phase four: is it
Secret Wars, is it X-Men?
Scott, I'll let you go first.
- Oh, man.
- What's the one thing we
want to see in phase four?
- Well, I think the thing,
and listen, as much as I am
a diehard fan of Secret
Wars, I mean, I was like 15
when that come out in 1984.
Yeah, I know, I'm old.
(laughs)
But I think the thing that
fans most want to see,
now that Disney bought Fox
is X-Men and Fantastic Four
in the MCU.
And Kevin Feige, he president
of Marvel Studios said
that was still a few years
away, but that's what fans
really do want to see
and that's gonna happen
and they're gonna reboot
and recast the characters,
just like they did with
Tom Holland and Spider-Man.
- [Mark] So there's a
vote for X-Men; Joelle?
- I'm also going to give my vote to X-Men.
Storm is coming, I don't know
when, and I don't know where.
I know about four actresses
are competing for the role
already, just sight unseen,
like, we would just like it
when it's available.
I'm secretly rooting for
Yetide to be Doc Ock, I guess,
not-so-secretly.
Yetide Badaki, she's amazing.
I also think that you
have the Scarlet Witch
and this opportunity to
make her the beginning
and center of the X-Men.
Again, what I just like
about the MCU so much is that
they do that great surprising of us.
Like, they're just like, you
don't know what's gonna happen.
You think you do, we're gonna
give you things that you like
but we're just gonna mutate
them so that they're new,
and interesting, and fun, and
I feel like, with the X-Men,
it's just, there's so much potential.
And the fact that we
get so many great wars
between the X-Men and the
Avengers and that could be
coming up and we're
drawing new sides and then,
but I really want to
see is more fleshing out
of these new characters, to be honest.
Kamala Khan should be
there and be amazing.
We should have America
Chavez needs to come in
and just kick so much butt.
I'd love to see Silk,
there's just so many great,
young characters and I think
we could build a great,
little high school young Avengers world.
I think it's what's been sorely missing
from superhero movies
for a long time and--
- [Maude] I know, DC needs
to do Teen Titans already.
(sighs loudly)
- I mean, their TV show's
really great though.
- It is, yeah.
- But, yes.
- [Mark] There's that can of
worms to open in the comments.
(laughs)
Maude Garrett, what's the
one thing we need to see
in phase four?
- All right, so I'm a
little bit overwhelmed
with introducing all
the X-Men and it's like,
how are you going to do
that when we have so much
happening already and I don't
want it to get convoluted,
so here we go.
(chuckles)
Hold your head, 'cause
your mind's gonna blow.
We are introducing the multiverse
and in another universe,
they're not superheroes
and supervillains,
they're just called X-Men.
And that's how we get the X-Men.
- [Mark] Wow.
- And that's how they're involved.
So they're not, so it's just a multiverse
with a whole new set of
heroes that are just, yeah--
- [Joelle] So now we're
following two separate stories
on two separate story lines?
- And then, they combine.
- And they crossover.
- And you could probably, I mean--
- So, you're having
people face themselves?
- Well, no, I don't think that
they would necessarily exist,
it's a multiverse but instead
of having your Avengers,
you have your X-Men.
- Oh, I see.
- And that's how they--
- I feel like I'm in a dorm
room with Donald Sutherland
and I'm saying, so you're saying
one tiny atom on my finger
could be a whole universe.
(laughs)
Our minds are blown and that's
all the time that we have,
today, on the Aftershow.
I want to thank my panelists
for not only an incredible,
spoiler-heavy review of
Spider-Man: Far From Home
but also giving us so much to feast on
for phase four and beyond of the MCU.
And now it's your turn,
comment in the chat section
right now, here, on YouTube,
I know you're already
probably doing it.
Let us know your take on
everything you saw us debate today.
What did you love about Far
From Home, what did you want
to see do better, did
Mysterio live up to the hype,
where do you want to phase
four in the MCU go from here?
We love hearing from
y'all, so hit that bell
if you're watching us
on YouTube right now,
that's gonna give you an
alert anytime we have a new
Aftershow drop and, of
course, subscribe right here
to the Rotten Tomatoes YouTube channel
for my expert panelists.
I am merely Mark Ellis.
(laughs)
And I'm not a Skrull.
(laughs boisterously)
Have a good one, we'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)